[Music]
always think they're the good guys when
they stand down to like they they stand
like next to a table covered in drugs
that everyone enjoys yeah and you know
it's one thing if it's fentanyl like you
said Like Cocaine like something that is
hard to crack you know but like when
it's a table just full of Wheat and they
go ah we got it you're like the majority
of the people either like weed or have
no problem with weed at this point
cocaine's fun too
um I mean it is but I mean I don't know
I can understand not wanting the cartels
to make money and [__] you know that's
why we need to make American-made
cocaine I agree with you I'm with Dave
Smith Drugs should be legal 100 down the
board American cocaine it's pure as the
Colorado snow now that's what I want to
see let's [__] make cocaine great
again now back in the day the worst
thing would happen Marsha be color more
baby LAX if now it's fentanyl now you
gotta diet because cocaine's fentanyl
our cocaine is Barrel aged in the finest
mosquito that the Tennessee mountains
can muster ah this is
Sam's this is Sam Elliott and I'm here
for the Juarez cartel
because nothing's better than taking in
some Mountain Air and a little bit of
boogers
and then the like a rock music
right you know they say the sunshine and
the Jalisco mountains is what makes
their cocaine so absolutely pure
it's like a Bluebell commercial
what makes the Jalisco cocaine so pure
and refreshing wow pure mountain springs
that flows through the hey can someone
can someone get a clip of this to the
Jalisco cartel I'm telling you and
because they have so much money to burn
and see if they'll pay us to do
commercials for them
it's doing cartel commercials
what do you buy the Jalisco cartel come
see the beautiful mountains of Jalisco
it's like the tourism board
let's go it's safe kinda
in the Marriott
by the pool come on down and snort the
beautiful mountains of Jalisco have the
best cocaine delivered right to your
hotel room door by a man with an AK-47
and a machete on his hip
guarding eyes
we here at the Jalisco cartel we're no
longer putting tires covered in gasoline
around people's necks and setting them
on fire
a new more Progressive Jalisco it's a
[__] celebrating pride month
down to a more tolerant Jalisco with
less exploding
the Jalisco cartel would like to
announce that we've increased our ESG
score about 15 percent
[Laughter]
is bought an ownership skit sharing
black rocks bought a piece of the
Jalisco cartel with a tentative
agreement to reduce emissions from
cocaine processing by 30 by 2030.
BlackRock committed to a Greener future
[Laughter]
huh can't wait to clip this and [__]
YouTube tell us that we're glorifying
drug use or some [__] or we get murdered
by the cartel oh I absolutely am
glorifying drug use it's pretty cool
kids and you should start young do drugs
[Laughter]
here at revenge of this is we think all
kids should do drugs look I need money
so even if it is some shady like Lalo
Salamanca character that appears in my
life and offers this money now I'm
taking it oh I'm Better Call Saul some
polite Mexican gentleman with snake
boots with skulls at the end offers me a
suitcase of cash
yes please keep promoting our cartel oh
[__]